So now that we understand how the FAT format works, let's
consider its strengths and weaknesses. It is easy to create a
new file, so we just need to adjust the directory table
of the parent directory and set the busy bit in the
FAT for the starting block. Growing a file is as easy
as adjusting the next field of the FAT. Space usage is
efficient too. If a block is free, then it can be
used and it doesn't matter whether the adjacent blocks are being
used or not. This means that the system won't suffer from what
is called external fragmentation. As for access, it will behave much like
a linked list. It will be great for sequential access, as we
quickly find and follow the links. But poor for random access, since
we have to walk through half the links to get to the
middle of the file and all of the links to get to
the end. This isn't as bad as it might seem at first,
because we keep the FAT in memory. But it's still not ideal.
Overall then, FAT is a poor choice for situations where random access to large
files is necessary. Hence, it has fallen out of favor. It's still a good choice
for removable storage, however, where one is
mostly just copying data from one machine to
another, and hence, only using sequential access.
And its space efficiency makes it especially attractive.